all right so we will go ahead and get
started I am happy to introduce Dr Pat
burkat who is going to be speaking with
us about both physics and Engineering
physics and we will have one more
Professor who will be joining us
momentarily Pat okay
great so I'm going to start with an
introduction of myself and then I'm
going to ask a few questions about you
okay so I can learn a little bit about
um kind of some of the courses that
you're taking now so
um as you heard my name is Pat burkat
people often understand often ask how do
you pronounce my last name so it's like
a little Burr and a cat Okay so burkat
and I serve in as chair of physics
advising so advising in the physics
department and I'm co-director of
engineering physics uh and I'm an
instructor in physics 61. um actually I
have Autumn 2020 there also in 2021 and
2022 and hi Mark great good timing
um and a little bit of personally about
me so I grew up in Canada and I often
say I grew up in a very large family in
a very small town okay I had about 1200
people it still has about 1200 people in
it and um my eight siblings and I were
all first gen high school graduates our
parents didn't graduate from high school
and so educate it shows that education
is really powerful okay that you can go
from you know parents with no high
school graduation to ending up a
professor at the physics department at
Stanford uh and my research for most of
my research career I did accelerator
based particle physics so that's a a
picture of the two mile long accelerator
at slack the thing on the left
um and I came here actually to Stanford
for graduate school to do experimental
particle physics and I did that for
about 25 years or so and then
um I kind of had the option at that
point I would have to go to CERN which
is the big uh complex in Europe to
continue particle physics and particle
physics was a really mature field at
that point and I wanted to be like a
student again get back on the learning
curve and so I actually switched fields
to observational cosmology and it might
seem like wow that is kind of different
going from particle physics
understanding the things at the smallest
scale to the universe on the largest
scale but in both cases we use detectors
that have billions of Channel also
readout like you know statistical
techniques and the questions are the
same what is the universe made of and
how does that all that stuff interact
okay so now I'm working on a telescope
project the telescope is actually under
construction right where I am standing
in that um picture on the right that's
in Chile a Mountaintop in Chile about
9000 feet up and right now there is
about you know a few hundred million
dollar telescope there completing
construction we're about to start
commissioning it um and then taking data
um so that is enough about me oh one
other thing my undergraduate degree was
in engineering science at University of
Toronto which is like engineering
physics and when I came to Stanford
there was no engineering physics program
and I would be advising students and
some of them like well I don't know if I
want to do physics or engineering and
those were pretty different okay and I
thought we need an engineering physics
program so a number of us got together
in the School of Engineering and physics
and came up with the engineering physics
program about 15 years ago or so and
Mark Capelli is my co-direct sector and
so do you want to go ahead and introduce
yourself
and we've got these animations going
here so
okay okay you can hear me
here
um thanks Pat Uh well I didn't plan on
saying much about myself but I came here
about 35 years ago
also from the University of Toronto so
I'm also Canadian lots of Canadians in
fact Jim Plummer was a Canadian from the
University of Toronto former Dean here
at Stanford I think electrical
engineering the University of Toronto
plumber
so I uh I grew up in a small town in
Southern Ontario and parents were
immigrants from Italy all my cousins
worked on farms
I worked on farms I I didn't have a plan
to go to college and
when I was in high school there was in a
Vocational High School one of my
teachers said you know Mark you have you
ever thought about going to University
and I said not really and and he said
well you should and so I switched high
schools to a high school that was more
that was better in preparing you for
University
um
went to McGill University
didn't intend to study Physics
originally but I thought physics was
hard so I guess I should try it and
um
was admitted to the physics department
at the University of Toronto for
Graduate Studies but I chose aerospace
engineering instead and uh uh did a PhD
in a fusion related subject why
aerospace engineering and fusion well if
we ever want to explore the uh the uh
the outer planets and and planets beyond
our solar system you're going to need
Fusion Energy to do that properly and so
that was my history
um
I show a photograph here down to my left
is the national ignition facility it's a
fusion experiment to demonstrate
inertial confinement fusion and an
engineering physics graduate Chris Young
is responsible for setting a record in
August broke the loss in criteria for
fusion and uh and that's a great thing
and in fact his advisor was also a
student of mine in mechanical
engineering at the national ignition
facility Nathan Mizan he went through
undergraduate me I'll tell you more
about that later mechanical engineering
and and then stayed on for his PhD in
mechanical engineering as well up to the
top left of the of my photograph is a
plasma Source it's called the Z pinch
it's a source that we actually run here
unlike experiments that we do at the
national ignition facility a few of my
students are involved in the experiments
designing the experiments that we carry
out there and on the big laser facility
in Omega we also have a machine for
learning how to study dense very dense
plasmas also Fusion related
and that's all about me and now should
we just continue should I
okay
whoops
so what is uh so today we're going to
Pat and I are going to share this I'm
going to say a little bit about
engineering physics she's the
co-director as well but then she's going
to carry on uh afterwards and talk about
physics and more specifically
um what is engineering physics
engineering physics brings together
three disciplinary areas uh as shown
here math
physics and engineering and you might
say well what is an engine doesn't
Engineering also use math and physics
that's true but you get a little bit
more math and a little bit more physics
in engineering physics and and and then
you specialize in a particularly
an area of interest in engineering that
you're particularly interested in
uh It prepares you to as we say here
tackle problems that are at the
Forefront
multi-disciplinary problems that are at
the Forefront of
technology all right that we might in
engineering we might not yet be working
on all right so that's that's where you
go with engineering physics
um
in engineering physics you could
specialize in several areas of focus
this is now once you get into the upper
division where you've already done the
core
studies that you're required to do in
physics and Mathematics and then you
specialize in one many areas and one of
those areas is renewable energy and
there we ask questions like how can we
use the combination of physics
engineering
to solve or at least address some of the
big problems that we have in renewable
energy for example right that's a Hot
Topic right now it's a popular one for
many of our engineering physics students
um another area of interest is and this
is the kind of coupled in some ways is
the specialty we call Material Science
in and engineering and and it asks the
questions on how you could design new
materials that Advance the performance
of some of the technologies that you
might find in in the renewable energy
specialty all right things like and this
is a hot area now too right Battery
Technology we if we really want to get
to a point where we we can reliably use
high efficiency storage
methods like batteries we need new
materials the new the materials that we
use now Lithium-ion batteries nickel
cadmium they're just not going to cut it
and they're not going to they're not
going to work
to the level that we expect them to work
if we want to be able to displace
other Technologies like internal
combustion engines for for
transportation for example
another
um
another area that students specialize in
when they study engineering physics is
electromechanical systems and many of
the courses related to this are my
department mechanical engineering uh
there you ask questions like how can you
combine physics math and Engineering to
design the next generation of smart
products these are products that exploit
things like uh
mechanical systems Dynamic systems
Robotics and and all of that needs to be
managed by electric circuits right
processors microprocessors and computers
Aerospace physics is a relatively new
one I think it's only about four years
old now in our specialty list
another popular one for some of our
undergraduate students all right how can
we better the understanding of this
space environment in the physics
associated with it to uh
design new space vehicles and control
space vehicles in a way that gets us
places and and carries out certain tasks
in space all right eventually for
example we're going to run out of
certain resources on Earth where it's
going to become too expensive to
mine those resources examples like we're
going to have to develop Technologies to
get us to other places other planets or
the moon or even to asteroids and mine
resources that are going to help us make
those batteries the new materials that
are going to be needed for the new
batteries right
so that's a popular one growing in
popularity and then there's one that we
call computational science another
relatively new one that might be about
eight years old and how and we ask
questions like how can we combine the
computational theory and algorithms
many of which for example we use in
gaming now but they're very powerful
algorithms to solve big problems in
science and and also to manage Big Data
all right so that's a popular uh
specialty and finally uh one that we
introduced a few years ago Quantum
science uh specialty and and that one of
course uh Quantum systems are now
you know they're not just things that
you read about in textbook anymore right
you could you could imagine Engineers
beginning to build computers
out of systems that operate at the
quantum scale right the quantum scales
uh cryptography as you know exploits
quantum entanglement and all of these
might be something that you see in a
physics class now but eventually in the
next decade or so you're going to see
more and more of that cross over to the
engineering side
so those are the disciplinary areas of
engineering physics and
um oh I don't forget I think I'm going
to now turn it over to you Pat right to
talk about
okay and there was one in the corner uh
of the previous slide let me just did I
miss yeah but that's okay uh yeah
biophysics about it because it'll show
up in in physics okay and so I'll pick
that up then so how do we contrast
engineering physics with physics so
physics uh really emphasizes and this is
actually an essential part of
engineering physics too that physics
emphasizes the first principles
understanding of the universe what do we
mean by that
um in physics we try to come up with
mathematically consistent predictive
theories okay theory that you can make a
prediction from that that describes the
Universe on all scales from the tiniest
to the largest and in addition
um
we want to understand the universe by
doing observations and experimentation
to test the predictions and hopefully
and often discover new physics okay so
that's actually the most exciting part
is not just verify what we predicted but
perhaps find something new and then
through something like engineering
physics we can apply it uh to come up
with new discoveries so we have in
physics uh what we call Pathways so in
engineering physics they're called
Specialties and physics they're called
Pathways in both cases we have seven of
them it turned out it does happen to be
and the first one that I feature here is
biophysics so biophysics answers the
question how can we use techniques
developed in physics to advance our
understanding of biological systems so
for example this little movie here which
I think will play shows some real-time
Imaging of a brain in a mouse and you
see those little flashes of light there
so basically they're Imaging all these
little flashes in the and they will be
able to stack all the flashes up and get
a really high resolution picture of this
uh brain okay and all the techniques
that are being used there to make these
things flash you know what is it the
Imaging and stuff relies on a lot of
physics and so it's using physics
techniques to understand biological
systems the bottom one is a retinal Pro
prosthesis so artificial retina that is
um being developed to replace damaged
retina cells okay and so obviously
there's a lot of physics in there the
person who does that Daniel polinker is
um his background was all in laser
physics and fundamental Atomic physics
and then he was also very interested in
medical applications and at one point he
actually had
um a bit of an eye injury in a in a
laboratory and ended up in the emergency
room at Stanford University and uh ended
up talking to the head of the new chair
of Ophthalmology there and that's how he
started this program okay so he has now
this this world-class program
um in in that area then another
specialty or pathway is astrophysics so
in astrophysics we'll ask questions like
how are stars born
um how do they uh evolve in time and
also a lot of studies of black holes can
we detect and study black holes so one
of the ways a star or set of stars might
die and um so on the left image for the
astrophysics bright there uh that is an
image of gravitational waves just a kind
of artist rendition going through space
and this is what was detected by that
detector called ligo from merging black
holes and then the one on the right you
may recognize this was an image of
radiation around a black hole and this
was done within the last year so we're
actually finding out a lot about black
holes now other questions could be how
do galaxies form and evolve what is dark
matter we don't know we know it's there
we don't know what it is what is dark
energy we know it's there we don't know
what it is what is the origin of the
universe and how is the universe itself
evolving so those questions are
cosmology and that's the kind of thing
I'm working on now another pathway is
computational physics and data science
so this picture on the left is a picture
of a textbook the authors I know all the
authors they're all astrophysicists and
cosmologists okay but it's called
statistics Data Mining and machine
learning in astronomy a practical python
guide for the analysis of data it's a
fantastic textbook it's actually online
and they are always updating it their
python notebooks and everything to go
with it so we use a lot of computational
techniques in physics and the thing on
the right you might say huh that looks
like black holes again so that is a
simulation of merging black holes so
that's an example of what computational
physics would be applied would be
applied to
um and then geophysics understanding the
Earth at all levels is basically physics
okay I mean there's chemistry as well
but a lot of physics and so these are
just two images that I found that I
thought were kind of Representative the
one on the right is the represents the
magnetic fields of the earth okay
between the times when the fields will
flip I don't know if you know this but
every roughly I think ten thousand years
or so the North and South Pole flip okay
so they're you know with physics you can
actually you know kind of calculate what
might happen during that time and will
we be able to keep up with the with that
change the way the birds and the bees do
okay because they use magnetic fields a
lot the thing on the left is weather
patterns and circulations and stuff
um and actually for anyone here is in
physics 61 we were mentioning the
Coriolis force and I was saying it
produces these things called Hadley
cells in the atmosphere and everything
that's all physics okay understanding
those circulation patterns so a lot of
uh physics and geophysics number five of
seven mathematical physics so this is
related to theoretical physics but
theoretical physics is like how do you
discover new theories in physics
mathematical physics is what are the
mathematical foundations of theoretical
physics and how does math inform physics
and physics inform math okay
um sometimes math physicists are winning
math prizes because they end up being
able to make big leaf leaves in
mathematics using kind of physical
reasoning so if you like both math and
physics then the mathematical physics
pathway can be good and then Quantum
science and information you might say
did I just hear that in engineering
physics so in engineering physics it was
quantum science and engineering so maybe
more a little more emphasis on the
hardware and how you might build
Quantum Computing systems and here
Quantum science and information a little
bit more on what is the fundamental
nature of information at the quantum
level so because the information is not
carried in bits that could be a zero or
one but instead you might have heard of
qubits so a Quantum bit that has a
certain probability of being a zero and
a one and Mark mentioned entangled
States okay so entanglement and kind of
information there these are the kinds of
things one might study in Quantum
science and engineering and information
but there'd be high overlap with Quantum
science and engineering you know a lot
of physicists do experimental physics
and we'll also be working on
applications that are relevant for
Quantum Computing and then finally
physics education
and so how can we improve student
learning of physics Concepts through
improved pedagogical techniques and you
might say well why isn't that just in
the school of education okay why is this
in physics well in physics we actually
do experiments on this okay the
experiments are our classrooms
um and physics education research exists
as a field uh since about the mid 1980s
um and so uh at Stanford we've got some
world-renowned people in physics
education research like Carl Wyman and
so there's a pathway for that as well
okay so seven Specialties seven Pathways
they give you a sampling of the kinds of
things you might study in physics or
engineering physics we started a little
bit late but I'm going to go really
quickly through the rest how can you
engage with the physics and Engineering
physics student community so you could
take physics courses almost all of which
are taught with engaged learning
techniques
um I had even online because even when
we were teaching remotely we were doing
things very uh in aged you can join one
of the physics oriented societies and
basically physics and Engineering
physics students just kind of blur
together in all these things so there's
a physics Society there's a Stanford
Astronomical Society that's very active
and Engineering physics uh
interdisciplinary Community that's a
little bit in a lull right now and then
the physics undergraduate women and
gender minorities at Stanford or Pumas
tends to be very active group as well so
you can look for those online are there
some sampler courses uh yeah there are
some freshman seminars actually when I
was putting this together and updating
it for this year I realized that we
offered almost everything in the fall
and so this is a little bit late unless
you're already taking one of these in
the future I think we should try to
spread out our freshman seminars a
little bit more into the winter and
spring as well but um The Freshman
seminars can be a good way to be
introduced to some of these so there's
one in the winter called physics in the
21st century physics 83n that you might
apply for if you're interested what do
physics and Engineering physics students
do after they graduate all kinds of
stuff a lot of students will go on for
higher education so either a master's
degree or a PhD in physics it's probably
about 60 percent of our students go on
and get a PhD in physics in engineering
physics it might be 40 to 50 percent
okay
um and but not always in physics like
physics will go over into engineering
engineering physics will go physics or
engineering
um then uh a number of students will go
into the industry or the private sector
so examples are data science engineering
startup Founders
um last time we looked at the data
um among our physics Majors like I think
we're looking at about 120 recent
physics Majors I think none had started
a company of the engineering physics
Majors I think out of 30 or so three
head started companies okay so they're
definitely is kind of like a choice
going on there
um then the in the upper right a way of
thinking so Public Service policy
analysts think tanks consulting firms
they often love physics or engineering
physics Majors because you're kind of
trained to think about any problem like
not just in a particular domain also uh
teaching okay we had the physics
education there
um even our graduate students sometimes
working on their PHD they realize that
what they love most about it is serving
as teaching assistants for you okay the
undergraduates and then go on to do
teaching or professional degrees like
medicine or law
um actually physics and Engineering
physics students do really well on the
MCAT and LSAT okay the standardized test
for medicine and law they're
self-selected they're ones who are
interested in medicine and law but um it
is a good background for that also we
have Majors who end up in the Arts and I
write writer dancer artists because I
can think of students who did exactly
that okay so this is not just in the
abstract
um they uh you know they have fun doing
physics and then go off and do the Arts
um so uh how can you you when and how
could you get involved in research being
involved in research is a really big
part of being a physics or engineering
physics undergraduate and I would say as
soon as you are interested we welcome
freshmen to apply
um and you might say well how do I apply
so if you want to work with faculty in
the Applied Physics physics slack or
engineering then apply to the physics
summer research program and when you get
the slides that link will take you to
our our site you'll receive a stipend of
five thousand dollars plus travel and
living adjustment up to twenty five
hundred dollars and a needs based
adjustment as well on top of that
um and we hold an informational lunch
typically in late November uh in physics
if you're in physics 41 or physics 61
we'll announce there and maybe I could
tell you when
um we're having that uh that
informational lunch because at it we
will then tell you about how to get
involved in this program some
opportunities are geared towards
first-year students okay we ask faculty
do you have any projects relevant for
first-year students and more than half
the faculty check off yes okay that they
do
um and we help match students to faculty
we have a spreadsheet you can look at
over 22 2022 positions to see examples
of what students do
um how do you get started uh the first
five courses in physics these five are
required of all physics and Engineering
physics students so this is different
from other areas of engineering we
require physics 41 and 43 or equivalent
some students will place out of 41 or 41
and 43 okay so you can start at the
right point in the latter some students
are ready to start in physics 61. all
physics and Engineering physics students
are required to take 6171 and 81. that's
new this year but you're all first year
students so it's not new for you it is
the way it is
um and so then everyone is really well
prepared at the same level you take the
placement Diagnostic in the fall to find
out where you place in the sequence and
we have sample plans that you can click
on later that show you the first one or
two years of how to get started we have
six different plans okay so that's like
never feel that it's you know too late
for you to start but if you are
interested in aren't yet taking physics
41 or haven't placed out of it then
definitely take physics 41 in the winter
and then 43 in the spring so that you
can do 61 71 81 next year math 50 Series
is is recommended for physics Majors
required for physics Majors recommended
for the others
um
and I am just going to leave this
information for when you get your slides
it's how to contact people for pre-major
advising including me and uh mark and
um yeah and I think we've already you
know gone over the Specialties and the
pathways join a student group and look
out for these announcements about group
advising sessions okay so these last
slides are more for your use uh later
when you get the slides okay thank you